hey I'm Mel strong and this is a lecture
on cloud formation and convection in the
atmosphere if you haven't watched the
lectures on humidity first go back and
do that because we're gonna be talking
about dewpoint and relative humidity
here
so to recap what we've been saying so
far is if you take a body air and you
cool it down to its dew point you will
hit saturation and as you cool it
further air molecules will come out of
the vapor State and form drops of liquid
on the surfaces that cool first and the
surfaces that cool first are the
thinnest ones which are usually grass
now the same exact process is happening
up in the sky when we see a cloud when
you see a cloud all that really is is a
blob of air that has been cooled down to
its dew point so the same process
happens the air becomes saturated as it
gets cooled further water molecules must
leave the vapor state and enter the
liquid state and what's different is
that on the ground this happens on a
surface like grass so what's the surface
up here well there are these little
microscopic particles in the atmosphere
you might know them as dust or smoke or
soot or this tiny little salt crystals
where the ocean waves hit each other out
in the ocean and make sea spray the sea
spray evaporates and makes tiny little
salt crystals that fly through the
atmosphere they find them all over above
the continents they're all over the
place and we call these things
condensation nuclei because they're
going to form the surfaces when water
molecules come together so here's an
illustration of the sizes of the things
we're talking about here so here we have
a human here for scale and first thing
to point out is that the cloud droplets
the little spheres of water that are in
clouds are actually themselves
microscopic so a raindrop might be this
size we're not making raindrops here
we're making cloud drops in the next
lecture we'll talk about how to get this
but for now we're talking about
how to get this these to get these two
different size cloud droplets water
vapor must form on a surface and the
surface it finds are these condensation
nuclei these these tiny little specks
that are in this diagram here so we can
look at some of these under scanning
electron microscope and dust can main
all kinds of things usually there are
fragments of rock though and so water
molecules when saturation occurs they
will start to condense on the surface of
this dust particle or it might be pollen
pollen has a lot of surface area and so
the the Centers of little cloud droplets
are often pollen grains or even bacteria
so there's bacteria in the atmosphere
flying around and water molecules will
collect on the bacteria some of these
are actually made by humans so this is
fly ash and these these little spheres
of carbon and they're made when you burn
coal and so coal power plants in this
country remove most of that but a lot of
it still gets into the atmosphere and
water molecules will collect on the
surfaces of these little spheres so all
of these things are examples of what
condensation nuclei look like so anytime
you see a cloud it's just air that's
been cooled to below its dew point and
as humans we can make clouds pretty
easily by just adding water vapor to air
that's already cold so we do this for
example on a cold morning so this person
is exhaling in the cold air and you can
quote-unquote see her breath which just
means that her breath has been cooled to
below its dew point so for example maybe
the temperature outside is 40 and the
dew point outside is 10 so we have
relatively dry air well think about the
air that's in her lungs right so your
your lungs are warm and they're moist
and the air that you breathe in picks up
a lot of water vapor from your lungs and
maybe the air that's coming out of your
mouth has a dew point of 60 or maybe
it's higher than 60 and the temperature
of your breath won't quite be body
temperature but it's gonna be pretty
warm and so you breathe out this air
that's pretty warm and as a dew point of
if the dewpoints 60 all we have to do is
cool it down to 60 and we'd start to
make a cloud
well it's temperature outside is 40 so
as she breathes out this air with dew
point of 60 is it cools down to 40 then
that water vapor that's in her breath
has to come out and form little tiny
liquid droplets and we see a cloud now
you might notice that on some days you
can see your breath but it doesn't last
long like it's just an instant and then
goes away in other days you can see your
breath and it seems to linger for a
while so let's change this a little bit
and let's say that the day is the same
temperature but the dew point is instead
of 10 is now 39 so notice that the dew
point is pretty close to the temperature
if they were the same relative humidity
is 100% they're not quite the same but
they're close so what we can say without
doing any math is that the relative
humidity is pretty high with these
conditions
dew points almost the same as
temperature on a day where the relative
humidity is really high your breath will
linger in the air longer because
remember relative humidity is related to
evaporation if I have low relative
humidity I have a high rate of
evaporation so in the first example when
the dew point was 10 her breath might
not last very long at all because the
evaporation rate is so great that those
little droplets are quickly evaporating
in this case because the relative
humidity is high her breath will linger
in the air much longer so if you see you
know you have a morning where you can
see a big cloud around people when
they're breathing and it seems to linger
in the air one of the things you can
learn from that is that the relative
humidity must be pretty high on that
particular day also and this is harder
to see but this one picture kind of
shows it there will be a gap between the
person's mouth and when the cloud forms
and the reason for that is the air
that's coming out of their mouth is
pretty close to their body temperature
and you've got to cool it down to the
dew point and it takes a little while
for that to happen so there'll be a
little space here where there's no cloud
until you finally hit the dew point
right there
and then the heirs continued to cool
further now there's another way that we
add water to the atmosphere and that's
the burning fuel so hydrocarbons are a
class of molecules and they get their
name because they have carbon and
hydrogen in them and they're pretty much
all flammable and we as humans burn them
so the simplest possible one is a gas
called methane also known as swamp gas
if you can't tell that's a small and
methane is flammable and if I light it
on fire it reacts with oxygen in the
atmosphere and it produces co2 that goes
back into the atmosphere and it also
produces water vapor that goes into the
atmosphere
or if I take a slightly more complicated
hydrocarbon propane so it's more
complicated because it's got more
carbons in it so c3h8 propane as is the
gas you might use in your barbecue but
when you burn it you react it with
oxygen in the atmosphere which then adds
co2 back to the atmosphere and also adds
water vapor to the atmosphere or it can
get more complicated and get a molecule
called butane butane as c4h10 this is
what they put in lighters you react it
with oxygen produces co2 and produces
water so on each one of these examples
as we burn this fossil fuel we're adding
water to the atmosphere more and more
complicated hard hydrocarbons not only
become more complicated molecules but
you can get mixtures of things so for
example gasoline is a mixture of
different kinds of hydrocarbons coal is
a mixture of different kinds of
hydrocarbons so one example of this is
when you start your car on a cold
morning and you see this bit well it
looks like a big white cloud coming out
of your tailpipe in fact is a cloud it's
water that's coming from the burning of
hydrocarbons so there's water vapor
coming out of your exhaust pipe it gets
cooled to the dew point and condensation
occurs and the other thing you might
notice on a cold morning when you're
sitting in traffic and you're behind
somebody else is you'll see water
actually dripping out of the tailpipe
and that's water that's from burning of
hydrocarbons burning the gasoline it
reaches the dew point somewhere inside
the tailpipe
because it hasn't warmed up enough yet
and drips out and you can see it running
out of the tailpipe another example is
if you see a coal-fired power plant so
this is one this is the Navajo
Generating Station in Arizona and so the
burning coal and on the cold morning you
will see a big plume of white coming out
of the smokestacks and that's all water
as you burn coal it produces water like
we've been saying the water vapor comes
up into the atmosphere chills of the dew
point and you're making a cloud in the
cloud eventually evaporates another
example is with planes and a plane will
often leave what's called a condensation
trail so this plane this jet engines got
four of them each jet engine is burning
hydrocarbons and as a result is
producing water water vapor comes out
and at first it's hot and you see
there's no cloud right here there's a
gap and then eventually it gets cooled
to it's dew point and you get a cloud
and there's four clouds for the four
engines so condensation trails whether
you might notice that some days
condensation trails are very obvious and
they stay up in the sky a long time in
some days if you look carefully there
are planes that actually don't have any
condensation trails at all or they're
very short and that's all dependent on
what the relative humidity up here is
the higher the relative humidity the the
easier it is for a jet to make a
condensation trail so here's some
condensation trails and on this day it
looks like the relative humidity is
pretty high because one of the things
that can happen is that condensation
trail can actually start to nucleate
into clouds so this one is starting to
turn into cirrocumulus right this one's
starting to turn into cirrocumulus down
here looks like some of these are
starting to turn into cirrus so remember
clouds really high clouds are typically
all ice crystals and so one of the
things that condensation trails from
jets can do is they can basically make
artificial clouds they'll make a little
band tiny narrow bands of Cirrus or tiny
bands of cirrocumulus
here's a very interesting satellite
photo taken one morning where the
relative humidity was pretty high on
that morning and you see all these
streaks all these little white streaks
all over those are all condensation
trails from jets so what we're working
up towards is we've got some little
puffy clouds here and what we want to do
is understand why is it that this cloud
forms right there and ends right there
and why is there cloud here and not a
cloud there that's what we're working up
towards but what we're going to do first
is get into a little bit about
properties of error so we're going to
spend a couple minutes looking at the
properties of air and I've got a
simulation from Phet called gas
properties and what I've got is a big
empty box here where all of the air has
been removed from the box we just have
two gas molecules so this might be say
nitrogen and oxygen would you've got one
of each and what I want you to notice is
that notice the behavior of of these air
molecules inside this box they move in a
perfectly straight line until they hit
something and then they reflect off so
if we can imagine taking all the air out
of a room and when we release say two
two molecules and oxygen and nitrogen
what we would notice is that they were
flying out in at room temperature
perhaps a couple hundred miles an hour
if they go flying out and start bouncing
off the walls and the objects in the
room now realistically of course there
is way more than just two air molecules
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna add
a bunch more molecules to this box so
I'm gonna add some small ones and then
add some big ones and what I want you to
notice is that in addition to bouncing
off the walls they're actually more
bouncing off each other now and this is
more realistic to how air actually works
if I had one individual oxygen one
Vigil nitrogen even though it wants to
move in a perfectly straight line till
hit something what it actually does is
it moves in a perfectly straight line
until it hits one of its neighbors and
then reflects off its neighbor and then
it moves in a perfectly straight line
again until hits another neighbor and as
it's moving these little straight lines
it might be going several hundred miles
an hour and each one of these other
movements but over time it takes a
really long time for it to actually get
across the room because it has to
balance against all of its neighbors but
that's how to imagine air that's how to
imagine how air behaves imagine a room
full of ping-pong balls just flying
around the room bouncing into everything
okay so now imagine that you are this
little guy here and you are pushing this
is a wall that can move slides back and
forth okay and he's got to push on that
wall because these air molecules on the
other side are pushing back at him right
and so for every square inch of surface
every object everywhere on earth there
are air molecules that are coming down
and hitting that that object so on this
you can see them they're bouncing up you
know bouncing against the wall several
times a second in real life maybe they
may be hitting every surface millions of
times a second and that produces a
pressure and that pressure is will be
called air pressure so in this
particular simulation there's a gauge
here of air pressure and then using a
unit it says ATM and that's called
atmospheres so in this little simulation
one atmosphere just to put in
perspective is how much air pressure you
would feel at sea level on earth okay so
it doesn't really matter the exact
numbers or anything doesn't matter and
the temperature in this case is Kelvin
and again the exact number doesn't
matter what matters is we're going to
make a few adjustments I want you to
look at how these two things change so
our little guy here can push against
this wall so I'm gonna make I'm gonna
push the wall in and make the Box
smaller and so I what I want you to do
is keep an eye on those two things so
here we go so I'm gonna push and as I
push notice what the temperature is
doing
and notice what the pressure is doing
okay so the pressure has gone up and the
temperature has gone up and also the air
molecules are moving much faster than
they were before and we've said this in
earlier lecture that temperature is a
measure of the average speed of a gas so
in the atmosphere if as we make it
warmer
all objects start to move faster so I'm
going to make open up the box and notice
the pressure goes down temperature goes
down and the molecules are going slower
and slower and slower okay so this is
one of the big properties of gases if I
have a closed box or think maybe more
like a balloon of air and I compress
this air right if I compress the air the
air gets warmer and the pressure goes up
and if I expand my box or expand my
balloon then the pressure goes down and
the temperature goes down so there's one
more thing I can demonstrate here and so
far the behavior of the gases in this
box is what you would get if there was
no gravity and what this simulation
allows you to do is add gravity so what
I want you to do is imagine that this
box now represents the Earth's
atmosphere okay so this entire box is
all of the air in the Earth's atmosphere
and Earth is down here and what I'm
going to do is turn on gravity and I
want you to watch what happens to the
air molecules in this box so here we go
now notice first thing you can notice is
that the denser blue gas molecules are
concentrated towards the bottom but
actually and it's hard to see this with
the red but all the gases are actually
concentrated more towards the bottom so
this is the way to visualize air in the
Earth's atmosphere because earth has
gravity gravity is trying to pull all
the gas down to the surface
and the only reason that all the gases
aren't just laying on the ground is
because they have enough kinetic energy
that they balance against each other and
continue to stay in the atmosphere if
earth earth had a stronger gravitational
field it would be able to compress the
gas closer to the surface so what this
means is if you were to say get into a
balloon anywhere to rise up into Earth's
atmosphere there would be fewer and
fewer gas molecules banging against the
surface of the balloon because most of
the gas is concentrated near the surface
near the ground and so on earth what we
know is that air pressure is highest at
sea level and as you go up and up and up
as humans it gets harder and harder to
breathe right so in Albuquerque were
mile above sea level a mile above us
here are about the top of Sandia Crest
and up there you know a lot of people
have trouble breathing by the time you
get up to say Mount Everest you're
30,000 feet almost nobody can breathe
and so air pressure decreases with
height decreases with height above the
ground and this is why because Earth's
gravity is trying to pull the gas down
towards the surface so when we talk
about things convecting in the
atmosphere we use this term called air
parcel and an air parcel is just a blob
of air you can't see it but when you
hear that term just think of a balloon
so here I've just got a normal little
balloon and as we just learned air
pressure you think air pressure is being
the result of all those little air
molecules banging against the side of
any surface including the outside of
this balloon now there's also air on the
inside of the balloon and there's air
pressure on the inside and that
molecules on the inside of the balloon
are also banging on the sides trying to
get out and it turns out those two
forces are balanced so my balloon does
not change size right so this the force
is pushing in and the force is pushing
out from from inside are exactly
balanced
when we talk about air parcels in the
atmosphere moving up and down I want you
to visualize a balloon just like this
that's moving up and down so I'm gonna
put this balloon in this little chamber
here and what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to start pumping the air molecules out
from inside this chamber so in other
words the amount of air in the balloon
itself is not going to change the air
around the balloon is going to change
and this is going to simulate what
happens when a balloon or a parcel of
air rises up into the atmosphere as it
rises up into the atmosphere there's
less and less air molecules up there
that are banging on the sides of our
little balloon so they'll be so there's
less pressure up there so this is going
to simulate that I'm going to pump air
out of this chamber so this will look
tube you can't see if there's a pump off
the screen here so I want you to just
imagine there's air being sucked down
this tube and we'll see what the balloon
does so that again this is a simulation
of what would happen to air parcel as it
goes up into the atmosphere
okay so we are now pumping air out of
this balloon and I think you can see
that's getting ordered and I'll step out
of the way here
it's okay so I'm going to turn off the
pump so I don't think I need to convince
you that the balloon got bigger so this
is what you have to keep in mind which I
want you to imagine when we talk about
air parcels rising into the atmosphere
as they rise into the atmosphere there's
less air banging on the outside of the
of the sides of this balloon or the size
of an air parcel and the air parcel will
expand so anytime air rises from the
earth up up into the atmosphere it
expands and it gets larger now one of
the see what I'm going to do here is I
am now going to let air back in and so
we're gonna see so we would expect that
the moon should get smaller so let's see
if that's what happens now
in a face-to-face class or what I do at
this point is I pull this out and hand
it to somebody in the class and I ask
them tell me how it feels and they grab
it and they're like oh it's really warm
in fact the moon is pretty hot right now
and the reason for that is because I
just took a balloon that was the size of
this and shrunk it down to the size of
this and as we saw in the earlier
segment when you compress air it gets
warmer the opposite is also true if you
expand air it gets cooler so even though
I can't really demonstrate it to you
here when we expanded that balloon up to
the size of the of this whole chamber it
was the air inside there was actually
cooler so put those two ideas together
if I have a parcel of air and it rises
into the atmosphere okay two things
happen it expands and because of expands
it cools on the other hand if I have a
parcel there and I'm bringing it down it
gets smaller and it gets warmer okay so
we keep those two laws in mind
so not only do we know that rising air
expands and cools in sinking air
compresses and worms but we can predict
exactly how much the temperature will
change turns out doesn't matter where
you are in the atmosphere rising air
will always cool at a rate of five point
four degrees for every thousand feet
that it rises or it will warm five point
that it sinks or in the metric system
the temperatures will change 9.8 degrees
Celsius for every one kilometer these
numbers are known as the lapse rates and
this particular number is called the dry
adiabatic lapse rate and dry means that
the relative humidity is less than 100%
meaning you're not in a cloud so these
numbers are valid for air moving up and
down the atmosphere as long as it's not
in a cloud adiabatic is a little bit
more hard to understand but if this is
my air parcel as it rises up or down in
the atmosphere remember it can change
his temperature it's going to expand or
it's going to compress and the
temperature is going to change adiabatic
means it's not absorbing any extra heat
from its neighbors or it's not emitting
any heat to to its neighbors in other
words 80 Bennett kind of means it's
insulated so we're talking about these
air parcels moving up and down the
atmosphere and we're going to pretend
that they're perfectly insulated from
their environment that's what we mean by
adiabatic okay so for this next part I'm
going to use a handout that I have put
up on learn from my current students and
if you're from somewhere else on the
internet it's on my web page and you
might want to print this out so you can
kind of follow along with what we're
going to do it's two-sided and we're
going to start with day one so the
premise of this is that we've got a
mountain up here in the atmosphere and
we've sent a weather balloon up and the
weather balloon has measured the
temperatures every thousand feet so we
know that the conditions of the air
above our heads now we'll talk more
about this in a future lecture but when
you have a mountain that's sticking up
in the atmosphere
the surface of the mountain will warm
faster than the air okay so we've got
three locations here where we know the
conditions at the surface the
temperatures and the dew point of the
air at the surface of the mountain and
the question is will the air at those
three locations rise and if it does rise
will it eventually form a cloud so what
I'm gonna do here is start with the one
on the right and get a calculator so
here we know that the the temperature is
85 degrees the dew point is 55 degrees
and the question is is this air going to
rise and I check the conditions of the
air right next to it which is 84 85 is
greater than 84 and air wants to rise
now you've heard the term warm air rises
that is true sort of if I have a blanket
a continuous blanket of warm air it will
not rise because any parcel within that
blanket is the same temperature as its
surrounding neighbors and it doesn't
rise but if I have a little plume of
warm air that's warmer than the air
around it then it does want to rise okay
so in this case 85 warmer than 84 it's
going to rise so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna draw some arrows to represent
this air rising okay
now question is when it gets a thousand
feet above the ground so as it rise as
it rises it expands and it cools
what is its temperature up here well
from the dry adiabatic lapse rate I know
it's going to cool five point four
degrees Fahrenheit for every thousand
feet and in these exercises we're
sticking with Fahrenheit and feet
because America that's why so I'm going
to take 85 and I'm going to subtract
five point four and i get seventy nine
point six i'm gonna draw it right on the
line because this line the temperature
right on that line is 78 so i compare is
this warmer than 78 yes it is so
continue rising so then I draw more
arrows and I want to know okay what
would its temperature be if it got up to
this height second let's subtract
another five point four and I get
seventy four point two and I look and I
compare is it still going to rise
seventy four point two warmer than
seventy two yes so it's going to
continue to rise as subtract another
five point four and I get the sixty
eight point eight now warmer than the
air around it here warmer than the air
around it here warmer than the air
around it here but here sixty eight
point eight is cooler than seventy so
what we know is that our parcel of air
will rise and expand and cool and rise
and expand and cool but stays warmer
than the air around it until it gets to
this point that means somewhere between
here and here our rising air stops so we
don't know exactly where so in this
class for convention let's just draw in
the middle so in the middle this close
this air right turns and starts to sink
back down like this so it doesn't get
this high right we know what passes this
point doesn't get to this point stop
somewhere in the middle this loop that
we made is called a convection current a
or convection cell and it goes has
another popular name called a thermal
and thermals are outside right now every
day as long as the Sun is up so what
happens is the Sun comes up in the
morning and the surface starts to warm
and depending on what the surface is
made out of it warms to slightly
different temperatures and little poems
the warm air start to rise you can't
ever see it but it's happening every day
now what will happen is early in the
morning the the thermals rise maybe just
a few feet and then they sink back down
by late afternoon they may go up several
miles before they come back down now
birds know all about this
and a big bird with a big wingspan it
takes a lot of energy for it to flap its
wings for active flight so what they'll
do is they will figure out where there's
a thermals right now we got this big guy
up here and he has found a plume of
rising warm air and so hit what he has
to do is if he stays within this plume
of warm air
he doesn't have to flap his wings
because he can just kind of ride use
that rising air his lifts and he can
stay up as long as he wants now one
thing that the bird has to take into
account though is in this case and the
one that we drew he can fly in here no
problem but the problem is for him is
that if he gets out here he's gonna get
sucked down this arm of the thermal and
of course he has a bird brain so he
doesn't know this so if you watch these
big birds but what will happen is that
they'll be flying around and flying
around and then they accidentally fly
into this part and suddenly you'll see
them discovery suddenly dive and it
looks like they're diving down I click
on the crashing of the ground but then
they'll figure out how to get back into
the thermal ok so let's do the next one
and the next one surface is 76
temperature up there 72 and the question
is is it going to rise 76 one with a 72
so yes it does so I'm going to draw some
arrows and the question is now okay
what's the temperature a thousand feet
above the ground
I take 76 and I subtract 5 point 4 and I
get 70 point 6 is that warmer than the
air that's up there so the number I'm
checking with is this one that's what
the weather blew and has measured yes
it's warmer just barely so let's do it
again another thousand feet subtracted
another five point four and I get sixty
five point two warmer yes it is keep
going fifty nine point eight warmer keep
going some drawing arrows this whole
time to show that the air is rising
subtract another five point four I get
fifty four point four
still warmer yes it is do it again
subtract another 5.4 49 now at this
point 49 is warmer than 48 so we know
it's going to rise but there's something
else that's going to happen because it
turns out the dew point was 49 so our
little air parcel that has been rising
and rising has finally cooled until it
hits the dew point so right here
temperature is now equal to the dew
point and what's the relative humidity
conditions when that happens relative
humidity is a hundred percent right
there and we get condensation starting
at this point and we're gonna start
building a cloud okay now before we go
to the next step realize now there's
actually another thing that's going on
and we talked about this in a previous
lecture where we said that when you hit
the dew point and you start making do
that the water molecules not only
collect into liquid droplets but they
bring in these little boxes of thermal
energy and they release them we call
that latent heat and the formation of do
we say that the time helps actually keep
the grass warm when it occurs well we're
now doing the same process but we're
doing it up in the sky and we're doing
it around those condensation nuclei so
as our water molecules are coming in to
grow a little cloud droplet they're
adding thermal energy to the cloud okay
so there's two competing processes then
as this air wants to rise it's going to
expand and cool right that's process
number one process number two is as we
condense water the water is adding
latent heat back to the air so so number
one cools it
number two warms it who wins well the
air-cooling still wins but what it means
is that our lapse rate is now different
instead of five point four degrees every
thousand feet it's two point seven and
it's actually varies on a bunch of
things but in this class we're just
gonna use the number of two point seven
and so this number two point seven has a
couple of different names sometimes the
wet adiabatic lapse rate or the
saturated lady abetik lapse rate or the
moist adiabatic lapse rate but all three
of these mean that relative humidity is
a hundred percent and you have a cloud
okay so just to recap it's rising and
expanding which is cooling but the
latent heat that's being added is
warming so the net result is it's still
cooling but not cooling as much as it
was before
okay so let's return to our cloud here
so from now on because I'm inside a
cloud I'm going to subtract two point
seven instead of five point four so 49
minus two point seven is forty six point
three okay is it warmer than the
surrounding air yes just a little bit so
I'm gonna draw my arrows to show the air
rising inside the cloud because that's
what happens so we're gonna go up
another thousand feet subtract another
two point seven I get forty three point
six so my cloud is growing and we're
making a little chemo form cloud like
maybe a cumulus okay
forty three point six warmer than forty
three so I keep going and I try another
thousand feet so I subtract another two
point seven forty point nine okay forty
point nine is cold in the forty to forty
three point six is warmer than forty
three so we know that it gets past this
line but does not get to this line so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw my
cloud kind of like this I know I'm
trying to show that it gets somewhere
between those two I'm just going to draw
it halfway well where does the air go
where the air exits out the top of the
cloud and it goes back down
Hey so our convection cell is the same
thing as the thermal it's just that this
one cooled enough that it reached the
dew point and so it started to build a
cloud and so what we're doing is we're
just testing every thousand feet and we
can figure out we know where the bottom
of the cloud is and we know where the
top of the cloud is the other thing this
means is that you actively have to have
air moving into a cloud to keep that
cloud alive I'll talk more about that in
a little bit so on this worksheet there
are three points on the on the front on
day one and then on the back there are
three more points for day two so I'm
going to stop right now with this and
I'm gonna make a separate video where I
work out all of the points on both day
and one day one in two if you're having
trouble understanding what's happening
here
okay so let's return to the initial
question which is why do we have clouds
in certain locations and not others why
is the bottom of this cloud here why is
the top of this cloud here so we can
answer some of these questions now and
if I look at on this landscape I can see
that there's different elevations and
there's different types of vegetation so
we've got bushes and trees and grass and
whatnot
and so as the Sun comes out it warms
this all these different materials to
slightly different temperatures and the
locations that are warmer are sending up
thermals sending up plumes of warm air
and some of those plumes of warm air
sink back down without making a cloud
but everywhere where you see a cloud you
have to imagine that there's a plume of
warm air that has risen up to a certain
point where the temperature is equal to
dew point and then from that point
forward you will have made a cloud and
it continues to rise inside the cloud if
we annotate the whole thing here so air
is heated at the surface rising air
expands expanding air cools it's the dew
point air saturated you have a hundred
percent relative humidity air continues
to rise inside the cloud until it is
no longer warmer than the air around it
it exits out the cloud sinks back down
okay so that's happening under each one
of these little cumulus clouds now
there's a couple of words to describe
these conditions if we say we have
stable air what that means is that if I
try to make air rise it sinks back down
to its initial position also if I push
air down it wants to pop back up to its
initial position if you have stable air
and this is a term you'll hear and maybe
in a weather report sometime if you have
stable air that means that the skies
will probably be cloudless or you might
have some little tiny cumulus clouds the
opposite of that is unstable air so if
we have unstable air in the weather
report what that means is that if the
air rises it's going to continue to rise
which means it will probably likely hit
the dew point and make a cloud so when
we have days of unstable air we often
get talked humorous clause or
cumulonimbus clouds and we'll talk more
about this in the next lecture so to
summarize what we've done today a cloud
is just air that has been cooled to the
dew point so if it happens at the
surface we get dew on the grass if it
happens up in the sky we get a cloud the
surface is that the water molecules
collect - are called condensation nuclei
mostly just dust the gravity of the
earth wants to hold all the air to the
surface but it can't so what happens is
it holds most of the air towards the
surface which means that the air
pressure is greater towards the surface
and decreases as you go up so therefore
if you have a air parcel and it goes up
it feels less and less air pressure it
expands expanding air cools every day
when the Sun comes out you get these
rising booms of warm air that are rising
expanding and cooling and if they go
high enough they may cool to the dew
point and that will get you cumuliform
clouds so in the next lecture we'll talk
about what happens if this process
continues and the clouds continue to
grow I'm no strong thanks for watching
you